[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 107 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I'm
Mark vandal and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie work how you doing
this morning Melanie
good morning mark it's nice and early
where I am where are you
how early is it where you are and was it
well that's actually almost 7:00 a.m. it
just feels really early when it's still
dark that's pretty early where are you
at today I am currently in the Google
Montreal office it's almost 10 o'clock
here in the morning so it's not as early
for me as it is for you yeah exactly
I'm back in San Francisco so yeah this
week we have the band back together so
to speak we did we got the band back
together just in time for the end of the
year to do a wrap-up of all the things
it was a really good interview I
actually did take it a princess back in
the in the recording studio and we also
got our director Greg Wilson to join us
as well to give his insights yeah it's a
follow I'm from that this week we're
gonna have a question of the week is
would have been your highlights for 2017
would have been your favorite things yes
will give a nice little highlight for
how our year went and before all of that
of course we need to jump into what are
the cool things of the week and these
are the last cool things of the week
that we'll have for the year which we
were just chatting about we were pulling
them together because we have all the
things we want to talk about cool so I
tell you what you just came back from
nips and you have a bunch of stuff
around machine learning why don't you
get stuck into that okay I just wanted
to highlight a few things in terms of
the fact that you know there were a
number of really great speakers most of
the content I've actually posted this on
my Twitter account that most of the
content was actually recorded and is
online and there's links for that which
we can also share on our blog but there
was a talk that was given by Jeff Dean
and his talk was titled machine learning
for systems and systems for machine
learning I'm part of it references you
know some of the work that's been done
and and the success stories that they've
had around the tipi use version 2 as
well as how they're applying things like
reinforcement learning to help with like
device placement and they recently
released a paper that actually shows how
they're using indexes and specifically
machine learn indexes that can replace
things like bee trees and hash and
and bloom filters I believe that may
have been recorded and posted and if we
can find it we will definitely share it
otherwise we'll definitely share the
link for the paper and one other thing I
want to give a shout out to the fact
that Fei Fei Li who's the chief
scientist of cloudy I and m/l spoke and
she gave some insights in terms of some
of her recent work around machine
learning as it applies to health also
something that if we can locate any kind
of slides from that we'll definitely
share it excellent
yeah so continuing on the machine
learning path there's a new open source
project called cube flow I can talk
about the kubernetes part you can talk
about the machine learning part I think
they probably works well so it's a
project dedicated to making machine
learning on kubernetes easy portable and
scalable which i think is kind of cool
it's basically based on kubernetes and
does machine learning things I don't
know about the machine learning part do
you know anything about a melody I know
that it helps make machine learning
easier that's pretty much what I know
right now but yeah people should
definitely check that out yeah so
definitely check that out if you're
looking for a good portable way to do
kubernetes and machine learning and we
have a link to the github repo furkupo
as well as we were going to share a link
for y combinator where there was some
good content and sharing of information
around that nice since we're on the
kubernetes train i'll bring up as well
there's a new tool we never get off the
train doing I never get off the train
someone was making fun of me on Twitter
about it the other day about how much I
like to talk about kubernetes cuz I do
of course you did
if you're using communities on us so gke
we just released a new dashboard on
cloud or google.com on the cloud console
that gives you better introspection of
what's happening inside your cluster
it's actually fairly reminiscent if
you've ever used the dashboard UI that's
comes built with kubernetes but as we
were talking about last week you may
necessarily want to turn that off for
security reasons but this still gives
you a nice visualization access to see
things like what pods are running how
much CPU they're using what services are
available things like that access to
logs directly all that kind of good
stuff
so if you haven't had a look at cloud at
Google calm and you've been running a GK
cluster have another look you might find
the new features kind of cool great well
I think that covers it for what we
wanted to share for cool things of the
week and
I think it's time to go and get started
with what our interview overview of the
year looks like sounds good let's go do
it alright so today on today's podcast
I'm I'm here to welcome a Greg Wilson
who is our leader in charge and I've got
mark Mandal of course who's my co-host
and franceska campoy Flores who is our
ex-googler who's returned from the dead
of going off to another company yep yep
for today holidays in Brazil in Mexico
so yeah a really hard life hard life
life what's it feel like we're in a
guest bed today you know still access to
food so good yeah yep so on today's I
guess we want to basically do overview
of the year we're gonna go back and look
back over time from the 2017 and see
what was our favorites and what was well
actually we should talk about what maybe
are some of the funny moments to you but
yeah yeah and Mark you should definitely
lead this off of it like what are some
of the top 5 downloads cuz you guys have
been here longer than I have
oh yeah so first of all thank you very
much to Greg and like Francis for coming
back thank you lovely to have you back
we have the new people with Melanie with
Francesca the history I think you can
say old people what's great so actually
first of all people who haven't met you
Greg why don't you tell us a little bit
about yourself from like what you do
here at Google as well you have a new
title now as well that's right
so I'm director developer relations for
cloud platform nice what does that mean
what does that mean I'm still figuring
that out after three and a half years so
developer advocacy multiple developer
programs to health programs engineering
all the things to make developers happy
reports up through our work so we we're
the receptacle for design cool
apparently successful if you were
promoted so we do things like you know
get the word out at events this year I
think this team has done over 600 events
going out and meeting developers where
they are and let them know what we're
doing here we also do a lot of content
we do a lot of driving better developer
experience with the products we not only
advocate to
the outside world on behalf at Google we
advocate to the product teams on behalf
of the outside world with Jessie I think
we all take that part of the job even
more seriously so we have folks that
participate in open source projects with
Google work with the product teams to
improve the overall developer experience
of the platform what are you up to these
days Francesca
so so you're director I'm VP oh that's
right double promo yeah but I'm the only
person in developer relations yeah so I
left Google as you all know one month
ago November first was my last day and
also my first day and the new company
and I'm working for a company called
sourced and basically what we're trying
to do is apply machine learning to
source code to build tools on top of
that to do that there's a lot of
infrastructure going on and there's a
lot of tooling that needs to exist and
we're working on middle of those but
then also we're working with like
researchers and people that are really
really good on like machine learning
which I'm not to build really
interesting tools like there's a demo
I'm working on which is like do not pre
invent the wheel linter that tells like
the code you're writing actually looks a
lot like something from this on the
library use that function is that things
like that which are not really doable
without machine learning so it's really
interesting nice that's good that's a
good problem to be solved there it's
also a platform like Google a platform
so my job is still kind of similar on
the way it's like like building cool
things to show the power of the platform
which means that you end up building
cool things so so it's I I'm having
having lots of fun yeah a good time and
how does it feel to be back it is really
good it is weirdly familiar does it feel
like you ever left yeah
I mean it's yeah I've been on every
episode until now to actually listeners
will not have missed you yeah I've been
gone yeah okay maybe we should know
are you still you still doing a lot with
go he's still close to go yes I'm still
doing go I'm still doing just a funk
like all of the infrastructure on the
companies raining go
and there's packages that they've open
source that that's actually how I
discovered the company like go get which
is like the most you get package waiting
go I buy them so so it's still a lot of
go going on which is I'm happy about yep
well since we have you here again
Francesca and Greg why don't we go back
in time we do we put in sound effects
right and Adam our course our harp we
cook back in time
and took a little bit about like the
inception of the podcast it's been two
years we passed 100 episodes together
which was fantastic Greg was there in
the beginning
why don't we let's hear from Greg's
perspective on kind of because we know
the story but what does he know every
coffee one day we're like we should do a
podcast and we came to Greg and said hey
Greg we think we might want to do a
podcast what do you reckon well it was
funny found some slides from an off site
that we did as a team in 2015 and one of
the slides and that was we need to find
new ways to reach our audiences and I
gave examples and the second example was
podcasts so because of that I'm taking
full credit but anyway the two of you
came to me and proposed a podcast which
I was super excited about but I
distinctly remember having a huge amount
of concern over your proposal to do it
weekly and I thought that was absolutely
insane it was and I tried to talk you
out of it I remember I said weekly is
never going to work you guys will do
like 12 episodes and that'll be fun
and then it'll turn into work and then
by episode 20 you're gonna be out of
ideas and telling me you want to go
monthly or quarterly but I was
absolutely wrong on that I realized when
you hit episode 50 and now episode 100
and whatever it's it's really incredibly
impressive how absolutely regular you've
kept it and kept it exciting and fun so
that's hats off to you guys it's pretty
awesome I'm pretty excited also I just
want to say Melanie's got some pretty
cool stuff lined up for next year
looking forward to especially the first
episode yeah it's gonna be awesome I'm a
super silent Melanie joining when I
first heard Melanie was getting involved
to the podcast Marc and Francis were
telling me a story of how guess y'all
were having lunch together
yeah and just you know having regular
Google work conversation around various
technical things I'm talking about AI
and you're so fascinated in Melanie's
description of it and her passion for it
hey let's go up and record a podcast
episode and so a few weeks later when
Francis made the decision he was gonna
go try a new adventure it was like the
obvious choice because she was so good
on it hey that's right so
it really just felt completely natural
yeah of course she should be the coast
yeah I think is mark that said maybe
Melanie and my reaction was like oh yeah
of course yeah absolutely and when we le
was like oh yeah of course
there was no maybe there I was
definitely Melanie so I'm super excited
about where that's headed I'm super
excited about where that's headed as
well and Greg is this your first time on
the podcast yeah I don't know how I was
not able to get my stuff in the podcast
even though I stood outside the door and
knocked and begged but that you could
come in the door right so now I know who
was blocking me yeah yeah so yeah this
is my first time but I was excited to be
part of it I wanted to wait so there was
a certain traffic level before I with
that said why don't we go and dive into
the top five that we found that we're
very popular within the community so
actually mark yes sure
well so number five speaking of which
where's the drumroll button today
number five is Vint Cerf that was an
amazing episode so like if you're gonna
listen to any episode I feel from the
podcast you should listen to that
episode yeah yeah yeah I also have a
recording of our faces without the audio
hilarious during that hangout because
like the conversation was amazing yeah
but the subtext of the conversation was
even better at some point have been
served so mark asks a question anything
SERPs goes that's a very good question
and you can see that mark was incredibly
happy your life has been perfect now you
have nothing else you need to achieve
yeah good question so yeah totally
though if you aren't familiar with then
he's one of the founders of the internet
basically the thing that allows us to do
this and I still my favorite response of
all time from him who's been asking him
hey you know you're building this brand
new distributed network we at the time
do you think that you were
gonna change the world with whatever
this thing was and how it's gonna come
out and he was just like oh yeah totally
yeah absolutely
how did you guys get him I send him an
email you're like hey vain serve so we
met long time ago at a cafe at Google
this is a selfie of the two of us and so
I thought that we're doing the Google
klappa phone podcast without the
internet that you invented Google would
not exist the cloud would not exist and
podcast will not exist so can it make
sense that you guess for a piece of 100
what do you think he was like okay nice
so yeah I was like who knew how valuable
selfie would be keep all my selfies so
what did you like most about the episode
outside of the fact that you were both
extremely excited and you have these
great videos if I guess the most amazing
thing was that we were asking questions
about what we thought the future was and
he was mentioning this like like for
instance we're talking about like well
have you thought about in the future
will need interplanetary communications
and things like that will tcp/ip be and
off and he was like oh no no he will not
because the ping is too big but we
already solve this with the JPL protocol
that we invented while working with NASA
I'm like okay that the future for us is
something that he has already considered
and mostly solved which was amazing it's
the power of predicting and actually
even adapting before anything happens to
to the future it's just amazing all
right what's number four number four was
a container engine with Penn Goldberg
I've done a couple of episodes of him
she's pretty amazing she's really really
really good and that episode was really
good because it actually helped us
understand not only the like what is
container engine but what is the
difference between container engine
kubernetes what is the community and
things in that you know it's now
kubernetes engine right and now it's
kubernetes engine that's true
yes well which is good because now GK
actually makes sense that's what we were
saying yeah but yeah it was a really
good episode especially because she was
also talking about the community and
things that that to us from a technical
point of view really interesting but
also I mean she's a really good speaker
actually it was one thing I really
enjoyed about
interview was talking about Google's
involvement in the open-source process
of building this project that involves
multiple parties and how all that sort
of flows together yeah really really
cool and what's number three number
three we can skip that one yes three
what's with Melanie worried Warwick
yeah I've not heard about her what was
that about
I'm not really sure I didn't listen to
it that's actually the episode that Greg
was mentioning where we were having
lunch at Google and decided that this
conversation is really interesting
should be a podcast episode and which as
many happen at the same day we did we
were like when can we schedule this and
I was like now this now so what what is
the difference between AI nml there's no
difference now listen to the podcast
yeah now the difference between AI AM L
just for the record yes ml is a set of
algorithms that are used to help with AI
what is the buzzword one is it ml AI or
is there something else is deep learning
oh the best words are all the best words
deep everything and ml big data all of
its birth there's a lot of buzzwords and
it it's used to make it people
understand really quickly what they're
trying to talk about without necessarily
having to dive too deep the realities
you need to dive a little deeper
if you want more of these alright so
number two episode 91 the future of
media with machine learning with Amit
Pandey and this was really interesting
because I really did not know what we
were going into there was your mark that
proposed the episode yeah yeah I saw em
it speak it was actually at the New York
summit he did a presentation on
basically practical applications for
machine learning for the broadcast
industry so film and television in in a
variety of circumstances especially
including sports so this was episode was
a really practical like this is how we
can use this thing now to help people
out when they do broadcast television so
like automatic highlights for sports
games cameras the follow interesting
action that happened things like that
yeah it was it was really it was really
really really interesting and they also
I believe talked about generating
content - which is yep
applications in general is is a constant
question in the space how are these
algorithms actually being used in
real-world problems so it's valuable all
right last but not least number one
number one of course episode 88 with Tim
Hawking talking about kubernetes 1.7
yeah so it's also I want to kind of
point out one thing here is I think
China interesting that kubernetes shows
up twice you know top five yeah I mean
kubernetes was basically like 50% of our
content we've talked about kubernetes in
one way or the other questions of the
week and now also people use it yeah but
I think it kind of does show the impact
of that project which we have
interesting I think there's there's two
factors at play here with this episode
one cribben ad super cool and
interesting people love it
- everyone loves Tim Hawking oh yes it
was it was really amazing how it went
onto hacker news someone put it on on
Hacker News and it was the first time
that I've seen people commenting on how
green ears no I mean commenting not
really about the Compton happens often
but talking actually about Tim saying I
just wanted to comment that I know Tim
Hawking from school he's an amazing guy
like people like that just saying that
he's an amazing you're in general in
that in he's really and the episode is
amazing because he talks a little bit
about well what is coming up and
everything but also his involvement with
the Prophet the project from the
beginning and yeah that you know he's
born of view is he was one of the
founders yeah so congratulations Tim do
you one the year we send him a new
t-shirt or something I think you said a
new t-shirt I don't think we said he I
don't think I got a t-shirt there's a
box downstairs alright so now that we've
talked about the popular ones based on
downloads what are some of the ones you
enjoyed the most in terms of this year
Greg I always enjoy the ones that bring
real customers into you know reaching
outside of Google the customers so at
Niantic that episode I thought was
fantastic plus I had a lot of
interest in how they were using our
platform and how you scale something of
that magnitude
Home Depot Broad Institute all those
were fascinating to me again real world
applications are crucial yeah and it's
you know one thing that's always fun
about being part of a software platform
is you think you imagine everything that
people can do with it and then you find
someone outside that looks at it
completely differently and then I show
you new ways to use your platform and
that I don't I always love that yeah and
I grew especially with that podcast that
you guys did at the beginning of year
covering Pokemon go just hearing some of
the numbers in terms of what they'd
achieved so far and notice of at the
time that people had walked about eight
point seven billion kilometers and that
was it you can walk 200 times around the
earth is the equivalent yeah for me the
the coolest part of that episode was
when Edward will was talking about the
impact that Pokemon girl had in the
world and specifically on his family yes
and he was talking about how his dad had
I'm even a mistaken it was diabetes so
he had to take some drugs and walk
around and everything and he didn't
really want to walk around that much and
since Pokemon go
he has walking so much so he was
actually taking less drugs nice and that
kind of impact is like you know yeah
thinking that you're working Google Apps
platform enables Pokemon go to help
someone with their diabetes I'm very
happy about that yeah that's like one of
my favorite stories is that story yeah
all right all right what about you guys
what are some of your favorites so for
me I'm gonna go with something complete
selfish so we've launched many many
products during the year and it is hard
to keep up so when we had product
managers coming and explaining what
their product was it is really useful
for us and for our audience but
specifically for me because then I can
tell people about it right and one of my
favorite episodes on this was the one on
cloud spanner to start with because we
have the PM Deepti Srivastava and she
she did an amazing job also especially
she was about to have a baby which is
amazing and we're like really like if
you don't want and she's like yeah yeah
you know I'm gonna make it okay perfect
so
she did an amazing job and also she was
able to tie it back to well spanner was
an internal thing at Google
and how he went from a project to
something like spanner has a service
internally and then how we make that
into something public on Google Cloud
spanner and that perspective of the
project that allows you to see not only
the features but why it got to be the
way it is is something that only really
product managers or engineers that have
been working in the project for a long
time can give so that that was an
amazing episode for me yeah I thought
that episode was pretty great too and
it's so clear in the way she explains it
especially when she covers things like
the cap theorem and how that's related
to spanner it was great yeah that was
really really good mark what about you
cool so I'll take a different tack as
well so we we technically started this
back in 2016 but we did three or four
episodes on sre and sre culture here at
Google and outside so we had Paul Newson
back again our SAE advocate he came back
to talk about sre after he'd finished
his rotation but then we also went to
CRE so the customer reliability
engineering which is the the more public
facing or the customer facing side of
the SIV culture that we have here at
Google so we had Luke Stone on who the
director of customer reliability
engineering to talk about the CRE
platform we had William bonell come from
Home Depot here's the customer side he
basically they a company that uses our
CRE and their experience so we got put
sort of both sides of that I personally
found it really interesting to learn
more about how we do site reliability
engineering what does that actually mean
for our products when we start talking
about like service level objectives and
service level agreements and like from a
customer perspective if I'm building a
product I need to think about how much
uptime do I have to have for this thing
and does it correlate with the uptime
that I'm getting from the products that
I'm using and how do those things
interrelate how do I deal with failure
knowing that failure is just like
something that is always going to happen
and like how do I deal with that and
post-mortems and all the cool stuff that
I think comes along with that I found
that a really interesting like almost
philosophical technical discussion nice
any honorable mentions well Melanie
what's your favorite your yeah I talked
about the Pokemon go that was one of
mine oh yeah that was
I'm gonna go with an honorable mention
to Paul Wilson because we have a
category on him so we should I think
three or four times so there's a
category pull new Sonoma we gotta mix we
gotta make like some coats like they do
with us and L when you've been on it for
eight times or something so one question
I have for the two of you I'm gonna
throw out there we didn't really plan on
this one but what's one of your favorite
episodes doing together like what's one
of those good memories back in the day
or funny moments or funny experiences
when you were doing the messages we were
sending each other when we were
interviewing Vint Cerf were hilarious
that was very amazing especially because
I was staying up late for this interview
I was I was in Paris after doing club
next Paris so I was destroyed iCloud
summit parties I was destroyed he was
waking up really early in Australia and
still we were able to keep the energy
and like just read sincerely have a
great time and yeah that's like kind of
energy that I'm missing now but there's
also from previous years when we
interviewed John Wilkes oh yes that was
a great interview so John Wilkes he's
one of the guys that brought the paper
on board which is the system that we use
internally that it's kind of like
kubernetes the internal google
kubernetes
that interview was amazing also partly
because mark was incredibly excited and
it was kinda taking mark to like yeah
that was really good yeah do you
remember what you were thinking when you
first started that's like your very
first episode and you know did you did
you have any sense of where you were
gonna take this or that this is gonna
really hang in there how did do you
thought this was gonna be amazing
we were absolutely it was it was really
interesting because it really felt like
a personal project more than it was
really mark and I we're gonna make this
happen and we started from scratch with
basically just like the okay from Greg
but that was pretty much it yeah we
didn't have the okay for marketing we
don't have
okay from anyone else we forgot to ask
we forgot to ask we just happened to end
and then at some point people were like
wait like you know you need to go
through processes right they were like
oh yeah yeah sure so from very early on
II felt like a very very personal thing
that we were both really into make it
happening but at the same time I was
slightly concerned about how are we
going to make this happen
every single week and and by the end I
really feel like we ended up like that
it just happens yeah well the one thing
I want to bring up that a lot of people
may not know this is not your full-time
job the all three of you are very
full-time developer advocates out on the
road creating content you know doing all
the things and you happen to do a
podcast that we could easily say as a
full-time job that you all somehow do it
I don't know how you make it happen to
be honest I don't know
okay that's fine yeah yeah one of the
secret sauces is we have now we have
editors and it takes a lot of time of
our hands which is very nice yeah yes
actually that's an interesting point
like year back to the beginning like we
started this we did everything we did
the editing we were at the site we did
all that stuff all s elves and what's
been great is working here and with the
team Greg and as it's grown and its
success and it's done really well more
and more people have come on board to
help us grow it further so the support
has been excellent I think that's
probably been the biggest indicator but
yeah I actually funny story I was
talking about how when you were like oh
you know maybe don't do it weekly like
you know that's a concern stuff and in
the beginning like we were like let's
try this out and see how it goes and
that kind of stuff and so at one point I
remember do you remember when you and I
Francisco said maybe we'll take August
off Greg will be fine with that it'll be
fine that was fun and I will never
forget the look on your face yeah Greg
do you mind if we just took a month off
we were probably six months to a year
into the podcast something like that and
I was like do you mind if we just took a
month off and just had some time off and
the color like this
like so is there any way you could not
do that yeah that would be a use words
like momentum yeah I thought I really
appreciate you guys stuck in there so
that was when we realized that all of
sudden it was not like our personal
project anymore but like people depended
on these there yeah now like oh oh now
we need to make it happen yeah well I
you know you get addicted to seeing
those charts go up another riot and you
know not share too many stats but I
think it's super impressive I think
total downloads is approaching a million
at this point and that's going to be we
might have to have you back for that
milestone I'm so happy with that yeah
yeah yeah any time for a free lunch
right side note yeah it is Saturday
morning and I've even had Ivan had
neither free breakfast nor free lunch
we'll get your saying okay so normally
we also do cool things of the week on
the podcast I think this is probably a
wonderful opportunity to sort of just
take a retrospective on GCP and talk
about what have been your favorite
announcements or new products or just
things who've been up to here at JCP
Greg I'll put you on the spot gonna be a
picnic maybe even one or two things but
it would have been your favorite I've
been here three and a half years I don't
know there's so many there's so many
launches that have happened spanners one
time it was especially excited about I
have a pretty extensive background in
databases and have lived in the world of
you know sharded my sequel and trying to
do things like that and you know spanner
is an amazing easier path for those type
of worlds all of the you know mental
stuff is super exciting to me I didn't
have a lot of knowledge in it I love
that we have this story from tensorflow
the you know very vibrant open-source
community to the EML api is with you
know pre train models the ml engine to
go do your own and I think there's a ton
of potential there and I'm very excited
about it even some of the things that
are sometimes not the shiny objects but
you know things that we're doing with
virtual machines continues to excite me
preemptable vm's
are amazing you can get an incredible
amount of computing power at a very low
price long as you just account for the
preempt ability of it which is not that
hard start times all that I don't know I
continued to be excited about all of it
yeah Fran says I'm gonna go with go on
that eight on a pension just because now
that I would don't work at Google I can
say it it took so long that finally when
it happened I was like yes finally I
know why it took so long any Tory makes
sense like there was a lot of
engineering effort going behind so in
the future we much easier to go what go
on the night go on the 10:00 but it took
a long time and I feel like that was a
moment where it's like okay yes I
finally I'm happy and the whole girl
community I love her I was like oh so
yeah Google actually cares about App
Engine for real so I was very very happy
but being able to say it publicly yeah
what's been your favorite Melanie well
more recently the fact that the GPUs are
cheaper that was definitely a nice
announcement to see research community
in particular GPUs are extremely popular
and that's that's a big deal yeah I
think think anyone's gonna be surprised
by my answer it's basically the
continual improvement and the community
and basically everything that's
happening around kubernetes for a
project that's been around in two three
years this year has seen a huge
skyrocket in amount of involvement from
outside sources the amount of investment
Google's put in the new features that
have come out that's just very exciting
yeah and this year I've started to get
way more involved to protect to more out
of necessity than anything else
I mean just the overall health of that
community and that's the tone of it it's
it's just a fine project people yeah
yeah so super like I just oh my god yeah
well I think we're getting close to time
I know we we want to usually wrap up
with the giving everybody an opportunity
to do a little plugging so princessy
anything you want to share before we so
so yeah I keep on doing just for fun so
if you were gonna keep on listening my
voice regularly I keep on doing just a
thunk and I just recently create a
patreon which is a new experience for me
and people are now giving me money hey I
know it's it's weird but yeah other than
that I if you really curious about what
I'm doing just find me on Twitter and
I've been tweeting about like
a medium to like blah I'm gonna be doing
in the future and stuff and if you're
curious about machine learning on source
code really then come talk to me because
I'm interested and talking to you what's
your Twitter handle my friends ask if
are a
Cesc there you go Greg you got anything
you want to plug just this team super
proud of this team it's fun to be part
of and appreciate you you all invited me
to be part of this today even though it
had to set an alarm for a Saturday
morning which you know very wrong but it
was well worth it this is a lot of fun
ja I get to come on other ones so I have
to wait two more years you have to wait
two more yes not with those shoes I
actually want to add the fact that on
all of the episodes that we had there
was a lot of the episodes that were
colleagues from our team and that was
really amazing it really felt good to
have every single developer advocate
from the team or almost almost all of
them we've been adding a lot lately so
oh yeah that's been hard to keep up it's
been quite a quite a few for sure ever
get a couple more in mark what about you
I have nothing to plug nothing's been
great I'm just actually Melanie thank
you so much for joining me on the pot
yes I definitely gonna miss you and I
have I do miss you but Melanie it's a
delight and a pleasure to have you on
with me now so I'm super excited to see
what 2018 has in store for us me too I'm
definitely excited about what we've got
coming up there's a lot of content that
I want us to cover and we'll definitely
cover GCP but we will also push into
some other things that are around
machine learning I know some things are
coming I'm very very excited all right
well thanks guys I know it was an early
morning but now I think it's time for us
to wrap up and get some food yes awesome
cool I brought the credit card awesome
thank you all yep and that's it that's
that's our wrap-up for the year I was it
was fun to do that and we had to do that
on a Saturday morning because of all the
conflicts that were going on with
everybody's schedule yeah it was a
really good chat and a good chance to
get together the old band and reminisce
about what's been happening in 2017
completely agree all right so question
of the week mark what's one of your
highlights of 2017 so many good moments
Melanie joining me on the podcast
clearly that is a highlight well
definitely miss Francesca it's wonderful
to have you on board now another
highlight for me though I want to
mention is that I started actively
getting involved with the community
ecosystem that for me was it was a
particularly highlight I've got a pull
request it's been merged into kubernetes
happens for the late this year started
to do some more work in there I've been
talking about crew noise for a long time
but I wanted to help get the experience
better around seek API Machinery is the
special interest group basically around
extending kubernetes and so I have some
PRS and some friction logs that I've
submitted to that for basically just
like documentation getting started
experiences like how do I get the
developer experience to be better and
it's been a really lovely way to get
involved in the community like my peers
right now I really just like not
necessarily code it's like read Me's and
putting extra Doc's on things in the
code like really like really light touch
sort of stuff but it definitely seems to
be making a difference which is lovely
so just really getting involved with
that project and getting started on it
good yeah it's been good
open-source man so coool open-source is
really good I am a big fan what about
you what fun stuff what do you think
he's been particularly special for you
in 2017 you know in terms of 2017 for me
definitely a highlight is the fact that
I started with Google and the other
highlight is the fact that I'm working
with you on the podcasts although I know
we've maybe we're forcing ourselves into
being that that's a highlight and this
is a good day maybe this is reverse
psychology a good thing it's a good
thing as long as we keep saying it that
it must be true
would you just keep saying and it
eventually will feel that way no it's
it's good and I say the other highlight
was end of last week at nips one of the
workshops I was in the best speaker for
me was having Gamora I hope I'm saying
her name right she is the first
deafblind graduate of Harvard Law School
and she is out there fighting for
disability rights and she gave the most
eloquent speech on thinking about
accessibility in tech and one of the
things in particular she really wanted
to stress was when you were thinking
about designing technology think about
it from this inclusion standpoint don't
think about having different tech for
different types of people one tool for
everybody and I really appreciated her
sharing you know her perspective and
kind of getting that point across so if
you haven't heard of her I would highly
recommend
looking her up and looking at talks that
she's given and that is my highlight for
the 2017 well thank you again for
joining me on the podcast today and for
the end part of 2017 I'm looking forward
to what 2018 is going to bring for both
of us yeah we've already got a lot of
ideas of things we want to talk about in
the new year which I'm really looking
forward to but before we get to that of
course I wanna wish everybody a good
holiday yes have a great break our
favori one gets a nice rest eat lots of
food we'll be back after the new year
for sure we'll be back I think within
the first week or two but have a good
holiday for you mark I hope you have a
good time with the family thank you and
thanks to all that listeners for
enjoying a podcast in 2017 and listening
to it we will we love having you listen
and send us comments and emails it's
always appreciative for me we run into
you in places and also just hear from
you as well
alright that's all we got well here and
talk to everybody in 2018 we will next
year
you